foreign
Baltimore Hey DJ what's up
hey hey guys
um so I wanted to see if you had some
suggestions on how to approach a
situation
um that my husband and I are trying to
tackle so
um I'm about two years away from going
to Veterinary Medical School and I also
was diagnosed with an illness last year
um that kind of limits me quite a bit
and it also means that I have to
renovate our home in order to make it
work for my condition so we're trying to
figure out what's the best way to
approach paying for those two very high
cost things without putting ourselves
into a bind when we're not currently in
one
so sorry
what's the nature of your illness
so I am highly susceptible to bacterias
and molds to the point where it causes
my body to go into paralysis
so um why does that sound extremely
incongruent to vet school to me
or that school it's a brand new school
being built in New Jersey that would be
preferable for me to be in during but I
can't think of anything that has more
bacteria and mold than animals
um animals actually they outside molds
it's not the same as the type of molds
that would grow like in your home due to
water damage so there's two different
kinds okay so it's basically issues with
water damaged buildings I got you okay
so you've got uh a a mold problem in
your current home
yes so and we didn't know about that we
bought our home in 2020 and it was
expensive how expensive to eradicate it
to be ready to sell
it would cost like about
five hundred thousand dollars no
five hundred thousand dollars for mold
remediation no yeah not to make you
healthy to be ready to sell
to sell it I mean you can't as far as it
doesn't talk 500 000 to remediate mold
in anything
except an office tower
no but I just did it I just did it at my
lake house I spent three grand
yeah that's definitely not the bids that
we were quoted for sure I don't know I
mean this has a whole house eating up
with mold
Yeah so basically any of the water
sourced areas so all of the bathrooms
the kitchen and the basement
you need to get three more bids
because let me just tell you the mold
world is full of drama queens not you
I'm talking about the the contractors
that do eradication and they'll come in
and go you're all gonna
get any they do this and it's part of
their sales pitch and you got it
completely you gotta start from scratch
I got like five bids on the lake house
and they were everything from three from
uh one thousand dollars which was
incredible up to thirty five thousand
yeah yeah so like the bids are upwards
between 40 and 60 per area that we're
looking at in our home to remediate and
then to renovate them yeah
I love you and as your brother I'm
telling you to move you shouldn't stay
there if you have a condition that
paralyzes you this house has got real
mold problems and so I don't know if we
I don't know if we're going to burn it
down or if we're going to sell it as is
to some investor who remediates it or we
find a better remediation thing but I
don't think this house is renovated for
you
you need to move
yeah I don't know I could move too can
you guys go rent somewhere for now while
you're dealing with the selling of the
home this creates paralysis for you you
said
yeah that scares me to death
I know it's it's really frustrating
because each I mean especially this free
gem that I live in like the Baltimore DC
area you know it's quite wet quite humid
um so I I really don't know where we
would go and but you also know you're
going to go to vet school in New Jersey
so it sounds like you need to move to
New Jersey if you're going to do that
so it's the it's a part of New Jersey
that's closer to where we live so it's
commutable for me yeah so you've
established here if you're going to go
this vet school you're going to stay in
the area
yeah and every house in Baltimore does
not have mold you know that right
I hope not but come on DJ
I would hope not come on it's mainly I
you know we love we love our home yes I
I understand what you're saying but we
do love our home and wouldn't want to
move if we didn't have to because we
just yeah long ago you have to move you
are not going to spend a half million
dollars you're saying this is at stake
and this place is is apparently rotting
down with mold
I mean you can't stay there
and there are other houses in the
Baltimore area that don't have mold we
live in Co we live in uh hot damp
Tennessee which is worse than cold damp
Baltimore for for mold it's like mold is
a way of life in our area it's
everywhere and and it's not everywhere
it's not in every house my current home
does not have mold my lake house got
some underneath and it was three
thousand bucks to eradicate it so I mean
it's uh yeah you but you've got to get
and I've got a bunch of rental houses
and we've had a couple of those we had
to do some work on but I've never had
one that was completely rotted down with
mold that is not so but and I have had
some contractors and some tenants that
thought that it was because the drama
around this is it's never ending and I'm
not suggesting you have the Drama DJ if
you've got an illness that is mold and
you have an extreme mold situation in
your house and that is in conflict with
your health and in conflict with your
ability to go to uh to vet school sell
the house for what you can get for it
and go rent something and go to vet
school and have your health it's a real
simple program I would not be in the
mold renovation business if I had an
extreme illness related to mold
it's the last thing you want to do
because the more they tear into it the
more it stirs it up
you can't live there while you're doing
it anyway if it's a massive thing we
fall get you gotta leave you gotta do
all this stuff and so yeah
yeah
you might you can't have too many things
conflicting for one go we have three
goals Health housing and vet school
what takes Priority Health what's next
vet school what's next stupid house